dear
fellow citizens a year ago on new year's eve
2014 we had to look back on a year
that had too many wars and crises in
store some things like the ebola
catastrophe in africa have since
disappeared from the headlines other
things that moved us in 2014 have
nothing to do with this year either
unfortunately lost the war
in syria and the bestial morning
of the terrorist organization es on
new year's eve a year ago i
said one
consequence of these wars and crises is that there are more
refugees worldwide than there have been since the
second world war, there are literally many
escaping death
it goes without saying that we
help them and take in people who
seek refuge with us
tonight i repeat this
thought because there has seldom been a
year in which we have been so challenged
to put words into action
2015 was such a year and that's why
I want this New Year's Eve  above all
say one word thank you thank you for the
overwhelming and actually moving
wave of spontaneous help that
we have experienced this year when so
many people have often taken life-threatening
paths to seek refuge with us
I thank the countless voluntary
helpers for their warmth and  your
willingness to work, which will always be associated with this
year 2015,
thank you to all full-time helpers,
thank you to all police officers and soldiers
for your service,
thank you to the employees of
the federal authorities, in the federal states, in the municipalities,
they all do far more than what is
their duty
they are all volunteers and full-time employees
have achieved outstanding
things together and they continue to do it
precisely at this hour there
is no question that the immigration of so
many people will still demand a lot
from us
that will cost time, energy and money,
especially in view of this important
task of  integration of those d
we want and have to learn from
past mistakes our values
our traditions our
legal understanding our language our
laws our rules
they carry our society and they
are basic requirements for a good
coexistence of
everyone in our country that is characterized by mutual respect this
applies to  everyone who wants to live here from
successful immigration but has a
country still benefited
economically and
socially, there is no question that
our country has already mastered so many major
challenges and
has still grown from them
on the third of october we have the 25th
anniversary of reunification
celebrated in germany
isn't it great where we are today 25
years later we have grown together as a nation
we have the lowest
unemployment and the highest
level of employment in a united
germany the federation has had no for two
years in a row  e made new
debts real wages are growing the economy is
robust and innovative i am convinced that if you tackle it
correctly, today’s
major task of moving and
integrating so many people is also a
chance for tomorrow because we have
great civic
commitment and a comprehensive concept of
national political measures  in europe
and internationally we are working
to improve the protection of the european external borders
to make illegal migration legal
to combat the causes of flight and thus
to noticeably reduce the number of refugees in the long
term.
germany is also making an important
contribution to the fight against the terror of
our female soldiers  and soldiers stand up
for our values,
our security and our
freedom, with body and soul, i thank you from the bottom of my heart for the
next year too, one thing will be particularly important:
our cohesion it
is important that we always have the
arguments  to hear others,
even if they weigh concerns and opportunities differently
than you do it is important
that we don't let ourselves be divided
, not in generations, not
socially and not into long-established and
new citizens,
it is important not to follow them,
those who are cold  or even hatred in your
heart being a German claiming it for yourself
and wanting to exclude others
it is important to want to continue to be a
country in the future in which we are
self-confident and free to be human
and cosmopolitan with the joy of success
and the joy of doing it
If we do our best,
the economy, employees and
employers,
so that the forces of the social
market economy can continue to develop
, science, art and culture,
everyone in their own lives,
and of course sport, too, when our
athletes next year at the
Olympic and Paralympic Games
and
fight for medals and personal bests or ours
soccer world champions in france also
want to be european champions
dear fellow citizens it's
true it's a particularly
challenging time we live in
but it's also true we can do it
because germany is a strong country in
this sense i wish us all
together health strength confidence
and god  blessings for the new year 2016